the bitcoin spot etf still has not been
approved in the united states uh you all
have the grayscale bitcoin trust and i
know that you've been pretty vocal uh
about getting that converted into the
spot etf uh talk to us just about where
we stand with that situation and kind of
what your thought process is in terms of
when it will get approved
sure so i think we got to take a step
back and really think about how the
sec's thinking has evolved around this
so if you rewind even just a couple of
months pomp there was literally just a
blanketed no there were no bitcoin etfs
allowed to come into the market
and that was fine because at least the
sec was approaching this with a level
mindset no futures based etfs no spot
based etfs and then a couple months ago
they approved the first 40 act bitcoin
futures etf and that was a big deal it's
a big deal for those of us in crypto big
deal for the investment management
industry as a whole and what we found
was wow now the sec is starting to
really move along move along in their
thinking maybe their thinking's evolved
because they've always said that they
had issues with the underlying bitcoin
market were there going to be issues
around fraud or manipulation was there
enough surveillance of the underlying
bitcoin market and what was interesting
is that the sec said that 40 act
registered products right so products
that hold bitcoin futures contracts they
had certain protections that they
favored for investors that 33 act
products which would just be spot
products products that hold bitcoin
didn't have
and so all of a sudden the sec kind of
had this kind of unfair advantage unfair
playing field that they've created by
liking one set of regulation over the
other
and then a couple weeks ago we saw the
first 33 act bitcoin futures product
approved so now what we said is whoa
maybe the sec isn't relying on these
protections as much anymore and those
protections interestingly are not the
kind of things that solve the sec's
issues with the underlying bitcoin
market instead it's things like
independent you know boards and custody
and accounting rules so now we have this
playing field where investors are forced
into using bitcoin futures products both
40 act and 33 act products and so many
of us in the industry at grayscale
included feel that the next natural step
for the sec is to approve a spot bitcoin
etf registered under the 33 act where as
grayscale is doing it with our existing
fund gbtc working proactively with them
to up list to the new york stock
exchange as a bona fide spot bitcoin etf
so as you've gone through this i think
your logic makes a ton of sense in terms
of their evolution that they're kind of
uh um kind of increasing uh acceptance
uh that this industry is here it's not
going anywhere and investors want
exposure to it what has been the
conversations with the sec or even other
regulators and and what is their
appetite currently and do you think that
we get a bitcoin spot etf this year
so it's tough to put a time frame on it
pomp i'd say that it continues to be a
matter of when not a matter of if right
the full resources of our firm is behind
this initiative and we will continue to
advocate on behalf of investors until
that approval comes through but i would
say that in the you know call it five
six years that we've been dealing with
the sec and regulators more generally a
lot has changed so number one let's
remember that they have a tough job
right even think about how long you've
been in the crypto industry and how much
things have changed it's tough as a
regulator to develop really good
regulations when the industry and the
asset class underneath it continues to
change new attributes new features new
use cases so in the one hand we
certainly sympathize with the sec and
other investors and other regulators out
there on the other hand though
as you said this industry in this asset
class isn't going away and so by
investors not proactively continuing to
advocate for this and then having
regulators answer that call and bring
these assets closer into the regulatory
perimeter they're really not helping or
really protecting anybody and so i will
say that while it's frustrating to not
have achieved a spot bitcoin etf just
yet that the level of knowledge and the
level of education that regulators are
bringing to these conversations has
changed dramatically we're never doing
bitcoin 101 201 kind of questions we're
actually really diving deeply into
protocols into the integrity of
blockchains thinking about the use cases
and really helping investors um in the
use cases that they're excited about
having those narratives brought to
regulators so they're looking at this
through a fully informed lens and so as
we kind of continue through this
obviously there's been multiple people
have put forward applications most of
those applications for the bitcoin spot
etf have been uh people who
aspirationally want to create an etf i
think you all are probably uh if not the
only one definitely the leader in terms
of we already have an existing fund it
has tens of billions of dollars
already in it and we simply want to
convert it is there any indication in
terms of how the sec thinks about the
difference between creating a fund from
scratch as an etf versus the conversion
process and are there maybe historical
examples of where they prefer one over
the other just like how are you guys
thinking about that
this is a great question you know we
were down at um the etf exchange
conference in miami a couple weeks ago
and we did her twitter spaces and our
friend michael saylor jumped on and said
that because of that differentiation
exactly what you're talking about the
fact that grayscale bitcoin trusts gbtc
already exists has tens of billions of
dollars uh you know over 800 000
investor accounts that are already
invested in it that the sec does need to
look at it differently than the way that
they might look at some of the other
applications in front of them which are
just merely ideas on paper and that's
not for us to disparage any of the other
issuers or any of the other products
that are trying to come to market we do
believe in the future you will see
multiple bitcoin spot etfs on the market
but at the moment the sec does have a
product that is trading every single day
in investor accounts small investors
large investors retirement accounts
really as widespread as you can imagine
with investors actually in all 50 states
so when you do think about how the sec
should approach this they do need to
understand that if they don't bring this
under their purview and allow this to
become an etf have investors have that
familiarity have that protection that
the etf rapper provides they're really
not fulfilling their mandate in
protecting investors so when you start
to think about this
the sec at some point has to make
decisions they can continue to kind of
kick the can down the road on these
applications but at some point they do
kind of you know rubber meets the road
and they got to say hey approve or or
not approved i believe uh that your
latest application or kind of the
current one uh they have to make that
decision over the summer you know one is
that true and then two if they don't
approve it what are the options that you
all have do you just have to reapply or
are there other avenues that you could
pursue that maybe could help accelerate
this
so because this type of product is
entirely new and would be entirely new
to the us market it actually requires a
rule change and any time there's a rule
change there's a standard 240 day period
during which the scc is evaluating the
application and importantly during which
investors can actually write in about
the application in favor of it or not in
favor of it so that 240 day clock to
answer your question expires on july the
6th so we have a couple weeks left
before the sec's decision to approve or
deny gbtc is ultimately reached
once we get to that deadline and of
course we and many many investors are of
course hopeful for a positive outcome
there are all kinds of options on the
table one of which we've talked about
before publicly is the idea of a lawsuit
and the grounds of a lawsuit here would
really be a violation of something
called the administrative procedures act
the apa or the administrative procedures
act really governs the way that
regulators regulate and so when they're
looking at two issues that are alike
they have to look at them through a like
lens and in the case of what we have
here they're looking favorably and
allowing bitcoin futures products into
the market but perhaps not allowing
bitcoin spot products into the market
and the issue with that disparity is
that both of those products if they're
really thinking about what their
hesitations are it has to do with
pricing and the bitcoin futures contract
gets its pricing from the spot bitcoin
exchanges and of course a bitcoin spot
product gets its pricing from the spot
bitcoin exchanges so what we have here
are two like issues that aren't being
treated alike and that in fact could be
grounds for a lawsuit to the sec